a brand new action RPG is joining the
Dragon Ball Z universe and although it
may look familiar at a glance there's
more here than first meets AI there's
quite a bit to unpack when it comes to
Dragon Ball Z Kakarot so we're gonna
break down what we know so far what to
expect that launch and what you'll need
to keep in mind before you buy as the
title may suggest we're walking in the
shoes of Goku and experiencing the
Dragon Ball universe from his point of
view the story is said to cover all
major sagas and plot lines such as the
Saiyan Frieza cell and Majin Buu saga
z-- we can even expect to see expanded
backstories to our favorite sagas along
with a brand new character and side
story
joining the lore exclusively for this
game accurate Toriyama even returns to
the series to bring us Vanya a brand new
character who was a former member of the
ginyu force with the entire story making
an appearance along with
never-before-seen Laura assumed as so
Kakarot wants to appeal to veterans and
newcomers alike since the reveal of
khakkhara many were wondering what type
of gameplay to expect you can consider
this game to be an RPG meets arena
fighter in an almost open world the
fighting style is similar to previous
Dragon Ball Z games like xenoverse but
between battles you will traverse
through the massive maps in go through
the familiar motions of any RPG like
training collecting cooking and many
other elements to level up and reach
your final form and although this won't
technically be an open-world game the
current maps we've seen are some of the
largest areas developed in a DBZ game to
date and even though it hasn't even been
released yet - day 1 patches are already
confirmed by developers cyberconnect2 1
will fix load times and another will
introduce general quality of life
updates cyberconnect2 is no stranger to
the world of Shonen in video games as
they are also the developers behind
other anime related titles such as the
naruto shippuden ultimate ninja storm
series and asuras wrath when it comes to
new releases you can expect there to be
many different pre-order editions with a
variety of perks that can be useful to
you both in and out of game before you
decide to skip that pre-order this time
around take a look at what they have to
offer first off there will be three
bonuses included in all pre-order
editions which are an additional sub
quest early access to BA news training
and a cooking item that will permanently
increase your key attack and HP if these
are the only items that pique your
interest in the Standard Edition is the
way to go
now the deluxe edition will also include
a season pass that will grant access to
future DLC although you can buy that
season pass separately the Ultimate
Edition pushes it even further by also
including a better cooking item a music
pack and even a fast travel vehicle and
if you're all about the collectibles you
could go for the accurately named
collector's edition while it won't
include the season pass or a music pack
you'll get an exclusive diorama figure
hardcover artbook and a steelbook case
if the arena fighter style is really
pulling you in be aware that there is no
PvP in Dragon Ball Z Kakarot the entire
game will be a single-player experience
but this allows for all special moves
and epic abilities to be enjoyed in
their full glory as opposed to the toned
down versions made to fit the balance of
PvP this means all of the mechanics in
the game to help you power up will be
that much more important soul emblems
and the community board will be crucial
as you progress through the story
because it will allow you to unlock
useful passive bonuses and enhancements
for whichever character you're currently
using that's right even though this
story is mainly from Goku's perspective
you'll be able to play as other
characters such as Vegeta piccolo
Gotenks and more although not every
character will be playable you'll still
get to use a few other familiar faces in
battle s support such as Android 18
Krillin and Yamcha last but not least
DLC although we've talked about quite a
bit of content so far there is already
confirmation of DLC for Kakarot future
two episodes with brand new stories and
a new story arc have already been teased
through the season pass and pre-order
bonuses so with that said it doesn't
look like there will be any shortage of
content after Kakarot release just in
case that rumored 80-plus our completion
time isn't enough for you and there's a
few things you should know before you
buy Dragon Ball Z Kakarot we hope this
video helps you decide if you'll be
getting your hands on this game and if
you enjoyed what you saw go ahead and
give us a like and a follow and be sure
to join us again here next time take
care